well the food truck industry is booming
here in las vegas too according to
foodtruckoperator.com applications for
food truck licenses are up 20 percent
that may not sound like a lot but it is
bianca holman is live with owners of a
unique eatery on wheels who decided to
open during the pandemic bianca that
sounds like a risky move
yeah it certainly is maybe not something
that you would initially do but when you
have a great concept like the sisters
star seed here i'm joined by jessica one
of the owners along with her sister back
there alyssa so you all opened kind of
just right as the pandemic was gearing
up what made you go ahead and say this
is something we want to do because
applications just this last year were
like 40 or so with clark county yeah so
we wanted to showcase our micro green
mix which is a mix of broccoli radish
leek it's got health benefits it's also
got a little bit of spice and some
flavor so this is our signature sandwich
it's a bmta so it's bacon micro greens
tomato avocado we make a bacon aged
dressing which is a homemade aioli
that's sweet and smoky we also have a
ranch club which is kind of like a
turkey ranch club but we make our own
ranch dressing from
unpasteurized cashews fresh herbs lemon
so no chemicals or anything in any of
our sauces and so you all have a unique
concept you know everything plant-based
what has been maybe the most challenging
thing to overcome during the pandemic
trying to reach out to customers i mean
find new ways new revenue is getting out
there getting out there and letting
people know about plant-based foods a
lot of the times when people see a food
truck they want french fries and burgers
and chicken fingers
and so we're doing a little bit
something a little bit different and
just because it's the weekend you don't
have to sacrifice your health you can
still have something delicious
and that's healthy as well good stuff
and i know you also had to pivot right
to maybe doing meal prep so we'll talk
more about that coming up because you
know they're at farmers markets they're
out and about in the city and i'm about
do you see that breakfast sandwich back
there you guys i'm about to bite into
this oh
don't mess up the camera chad all right
but everything looks so good so again
you know those food truck businesses
when they have to pivot they pivot so
we're going to talk more about how they
pivoted during the pandemic coming up in
the next half hour i'm going to send it
back to you guys in the studio chad's
zooming so much to get that food he ran
into the truck yeah he's like what
camera what lens what lens i got nothing
i don't know what's going on